So I'm going to start talking to you
about Pinocchio a little bit.
Weirdly enough,
I hope you enjoy this,
and the reason I want to do it is
because I want to.
I want to put some.
I want to bring what I told you
abstractly down to earth and then you
can start thinking,
well,
do the conceptions that I've introduced
to you,
are they,
are they good for anything?
Did they help?
That's the order.
Descend into chaos,
reestablishment of order.
That's paradise lost.
Profane history,
paradise regained.
It's the classic comedy and that's the
story of life.
And so the question is how do you manage
it?
And so that's a question you really want
to know the answer to.
So you'll go,
you'll pay money weirdly,
you'll line up and pay money to see a
story about that even if you don't even
know that that's what the story is
about.
And the reason for that is that actually
part of you doesn't know what the
story's about.
You know you have your cognition has
multiple layers.
You understand things that you don't
know you understand in ways that you
don't understand and you can tell that
because you know,
we,
we talked about Pinocchio a little bit,
how absurd it is and that it doesn't
matter.
Well,
so we've been talking.
People don't do what they expect you to
do it in the negative sense.
What if the reaction is extremely
positive,
like something that click like winning a
lottery.
Does that,
do you also go into the stress response
so you the same thing?
Not Quite the same thing.
It's a good question and we will address
that.
We will address that.
I mean winning the lottery is generally
not a good idea for people,
you know,
because it's just too much.
It's too much for them.
Flips their lives upside down so.
And they tend to at best to return to
their original baseline level of
emotion.
But yeah,
something remarkably good.
I mean it's a lot better than something
remarkably bad obviously,
but it still can have that destabilizing
effect.
So it depends on what elements of your
life it disrupts it.
Like it's some,
some in some sense you have a map that
you're operating within in the world and
that map is predicated on assumptions of
different sorts,
some shallow,
some profound when the profound
assumptions are devastated,
huge chunks of the map or invalidated.
And that can happen sometimes when
dramatically positive things happen as
well.
So,
but the fundamental rule is the more of
your axiomatic presuppositions
are disrupted,
the harder it is on you.
You know,
like maybe you quit your job because you
win the lottery.
It's like,
Hey,
I'm off to the beach,
I'm going to drink Margaritas.
So that'll work for about four days.
You know,
you do that for three months,
you're a,
you're a beach alcoholic.
It's like that's a real improvement,
you know,
so it's not that easy.
And often too,
if you take people out of their routine,
you know,
they just flounder.
Their circadian rhythms go.
They don't eat properly,
they don't know what the hell to do,
you know.
So this is often why people have such a
hard time when they retire.
I'm going to retire and relax.
It's like fire relaxed for two weeks.
I would die,
you know,
I need something to do.
I need to be engaged in something.
So,
okay.
Pinocchio,
Disney movie and early one a
masterpiece.
And so I'm going to walk you through it
and I'm going to tell you what I think
it means and you can tell me if you
think that that's useful.
And I'm only going to do that for about
10 minutes today because I do want to
cover some of the details of the class.
And then next class we'll continue with
this.
So,
so the movie opens with the opening
credits which are carved wooden signs,
which is like a hint,
you know,
because Japan was a carver and it starts
with this song which was actually quite
a popular song and it's a bit of a,
what would you call it?
I don't think it's,
the poetry is particularly profound,
but it was a song that people liked and
people still listened to.
And um,
it sets the tone for the movie,
which is what music does.
One of the things that's really
interesting about movies,
it's really mysterious is that,
you know,
if you go to a movie,
there's almost always a soundtrack,
right?
If you go to a movie and the reason to
soundtrack it,
it kind of feels empty.
It feels like there's something missing
and you know,
it's as if the music,
you know,
when you go to a movie,
there's lots of things you can't see.
The characters are only partial and you
don't know anything about their
background.
So it's like a low resolution thing.
What seems to happen with the music is
that it provides the emotional
background,
the complex context,
let's say it's like a substitute for the
context and it,
it guides you in your,
in your perceptions of the movie.
It gives you hints about what's going to
happen.
And,
and,
and the funny thing about that is,
is that we just,
we just don't have any problem with
that.
You know,
it's like,
yeah,
of course movie has its own track and,
and of course when there's a dramatic
scene and the music gets dramatic and,
but that doesn't happen in real life.
So you'd wonder why we would accept it
in a movie and I think it's partly
because we're willing to accept the
amplification of reality that
constitutes a movie and in fact we find
that compelling and music is one of the
things that does that amplification the
dramatization,
and that's,
that's acceptable to us.
This song I find quite interesting.
So I'm going to take it apart quite a
bit.
Um,
in some sense I feel foolish doing it
because it's,
you know,
it's a,
it's a childish,
it's a childish song in some ways,
but,
but that's okay.
When you wish upon a star,
makes no difference who you are.
Well,
okay,
there's some mysteries there people wish
upon stars.
That's like a little ritual,
right?
Why do they do that?
Well,
and what exactly is the star?
That's another question because there
are stars that shine in the heavens and
there are people who are stars.
And so
why are people stars while they're
usually famous people,
right?
There are people that who attract a lot
of attention and maybe there are people
who have a lot of talent.
That's another possibility.
Um,
maybe their models.
I don't mean you know,
clothing models,
although sometimes they are,
but there are models for emulation.
That's what being a star means.
That's why people magazine is full of
stars.
It's like they're,
they're like,
they're like heroes brought to earth and
of course you know nothing about them.
All,
you know is their public persona and of
course they're usually very attractive
and so that allows you to project upon
them all of the things that would go
along with ideal humanity and so their
stars and,
but still why stars stars beckon in the
darkness,
right?
And their other worldly.
That's the thing.
That's cool.
They're not of this earth and I mean
that technically because obviously
they're not of this earth,
but I also mean it.
I mean it phenomenologically I mean it
as an element of human experience.
So most of you are urban and so you've
not had the experience of perhaps of the
full night sky,
you know,
and that's really too bad because the
full night's sky is one of those
experiences that actually induces all
naturally,
you know,
and no wonder you look up there and
there's just stars everywhere,
right?
You're looking at the edge of the
galaxy.
That's actually,
that's the Milky Way,
right?
It's the edge of the galaxy.
It's like,
wow,
there's the edge of the galaxy and
there's just so many of them and it's
such an expansive.
You're looking into infinity,
you're looking into the unknown,
you're looking beyond yourself,
that's for sure.
And you know,
that produces a sense of awe in people
like looking at the Grand Canyon or
something like that.
And you're looking at something that
transcends yourself.
But that feeling of awe,
that seems to be something that's,
that's,
that's a natural part.
Our response,
you know,
you might feel,
or when you meet someone that you regard
as particularly admirable as well
because you'll feel that there's
something transcendent about them.
So here's an interesting thing to think
about.
There are people you admire and there
are people that you don't admire and
that's a clue,
right?
That's a clue as to your value system
and it might be not really something you
can even put your finger on.
It's like if you find this person
captivating,
you find this person and admirable and
it's,
it's as if there's something inside of
you that's looking for what's admirable,
you know,
assuming that you are and that person
who's admirable has a,
has a faculty,
some faculty that you would like to have
for yourself.
And so there are a model for emulation
and that's part of how people develop.
You know,
like little kids often develop little
hero crushes on older kids,
you know,
not that much older,
but sort of the person that sort of just
within their grasp and then they follow
them around and imitate them and you
know,
so they're imitating what they find
admirable.
Well,
the fact that you find something
admirable as a hint,
as to the structure of your unconscious
value system.
And so you could think even as an
exercise,
you can take well what qualities of a
human being do I find admirable?
You have to ask yourself that in a
sense.
You can't really think about it.
There is a difference between asking
yourself a question and thinking about
it,
you know,
because it's more like when you're
asking yourself a question,
it's contemplating,
it's like,
well,
what do I find admirable?
It's question you don't know.
And if you're fortunate and this happens
quite regularly,
an answer will float up from wherever
the hell answers float up.
And you know,
Oh yeah,
that's one.
And you can write that down and you get
some idea of what your ideal is,
you know,
and you have one likely.
And what your counter ideal is.